حاول الطبيبه ان تسرق منها الامل لكنها
فشلت مرتين كطبيبه وكانسانه هذا ما حدث مع
ارتيميا التي نسيت حياتها تماما لتغرق في
البحث عن مصادر وكتب موثوقه تدلها الى
الطريق للوصول الى ابنها لم تكن مهمتها
سهله بسبب ندره الكتب التعليميه واللافت
هنا ان من كتب غالبيه الكتب عن التوحد هم
اصحاب توحد
المعالجين قال لي انه يجب ان اقوم ببعض
التمارين معه وهو تمرين تذوق الماء المالح
والحلم والمر والحامض لتحفيز الاحساس لديه
[موسيقى]
صوره الهاتف
جيد جدا
اين صوره الطبخ جيد جدا ميراج اخرجت الامل
من الالم لتوصل ابنها الى القراءه
والكتابه والرسم والتعبير عن نفسه وحتى
المشاركه في مسابقات ومنافسات مع اخرين هم
ليسوا في عالم خاص بهم هم في عالمنا
[موسيقى]
كان الامر صعبا في البدايه وسبب ضغطا
نفسيا والان ارى ابني يمكنه الكلام وقادر
على ان يطلب ما يشاء ولديه سلوك جيد في
المجتمع وكل يوم يتعلم اشياء كثيره انا
ارى ابني طفلا عاديا لا اريد طفلا اخر
بديلا عنه